Merci.
Ah merde !
Si vraiment tu veux que ton corps soit en pleine santé, mange de la raclette !
FAUX !
Récemment j'ai fait une raclette entre potes et c'est vrai que ce plat il a un petit côté bonne ambiance , bon délire qui fait plaisir à tout le monde.
Sauf qu'à chaque fois on y retrouve toujours exactement la même chose : il y a toujours ce con qui met la poêle au dessus, alors que c'est
fait pour les patates.
"Ben quoi ?". Il y a toujours ce débat avec ou sans croûte : "Euh quoi tu manges pas ta croûte ?
Pourtant moi je mange que ça !". Il y a toujours une embrouille sur à qui appartient quoi : "Attend, ça c'est ma pomme de terre !".
"C'est à tout le monde les pommes de terre en fait donc ..." - "Non, non celle-ci je l'avais réservé !"
Il y a toujours une poêle perdu, personne sait à qui elle est.
"Oh c'est a qui cette poêle toute seule ?" - "Euh, c'est pas à moi.." - "Moi non plus !"
*Fromage* : "Oh pourquoi personne veut de moi ? Ah je meurs !"
Il y a toujours un mec qui se prend pour un chef cuistot, et puis surtout il y a toujours Gilles Raclette qui ramène sa science.
"Alors ça en fait c'est pas de la vraie hein, la vraie raclée traditionnelle suisse c'est un demi fromage qu'on racle
d'où le nom raclette ! Ca, ça vient de là."
"Ah oui bah donc t'en veux pas alors." -
"Ah bah si j'en veux, j'en veux quand même.."
"Ah bah non attend, c'est pas traditionnel je ne vais quand-même pas te laisser manger ça, tu rigoles!"
Alors déjà, le principe de la raclette c'est que ça se partage, le faire tout seul c'est un peu triste.
"Eh mais elle est à qui cette poêle là ?
Bah...elle est à moi parce que je suis tout seul.."
Quand tu manges une raclette physiquement tu es à ton pire : tu as la bouche luisant de gras, t'as le ventre rempli, t'es rouge, t'es bourré
T'es, t'es Depardieu quoi.. Et c'est vrai que la raclette c'est un truc qu'on mange en famille, entre proches comme si c'était la honte !
"Je suis venu pour la raclette" - "T'as pas été suivi ?" -  "Non"
"Ok c'est quoi le mot de passe ?" - "Les poêlons son chaud,  archi chaud"
"C'est bon tu peux rentrer"
"T'as le matos ?" - "6 mois d'affinage" -
"Et c'est parti !"
La raclette c'est pas un plat normal, c'est clairement une orgie de bouffe ultra calorique ! Pourtant on veut toujours se donner un peu bonne conscience..
"T'es sérieux là ?!"
"Alors toi ta santé t'en a absolument rien à foutre quoi !" - "Ma santé ? Beh je sais...Bah ...Je sais pas c'est ..."
"Voilà ! C'est pas compliqué de manger un peu équilibré quoi ! Enfin je sais pas, je ..."
Attention quand tu manges une raclette, vaut mieux être bien placé sur la table, parce que si tu es trop près de la machine,
si tu bois du vin, bah ça devient du vin chaud... "Ah !" Ton avant bras est carrément
carbonisé... T'as le visage rouge écarlate, et la tête prête à exploser...
"T'as pas la clim ?". L'avantage avec la raquette c'est que finalement tes invités, ils s'amusent à se faire à manger eux-mêmes ! Ça c'est pratique!"
Par contre après, ils s'amusent pas à faire la vaisselle !
Hein, ça c'est pour toi ! Et la vaisselle d'une raclette c'est pas une simple vaisselle, c'est le chaos !
"Mais qu'est ce qui s'est passé ?"
"Ça, c'est une Z.D.R. ! Ouais, Zone De Raclette. Le périmètre a été bouclé à près de 3 kilomètres à la ronde
à cause de l'odeur de fromage,
et nos meilleurs experts estiment les dégâts à près de 3 jours de vaisselle !"
"Chef, regardez ce que j'ai trouvé !" -
"C'est du jambon ?" - "Exactement et il est encore tiède !" - "Envoyez ça au labo."
"Ça vous rappelle rien ?"
"L'affaire de la fondu.." Alors oui une raclette ça dure toujours une éternité, hein ! Il y a toujours deux personnes qui veulent pas s'arrêter ..
"Ok je te relance de deux patates"
"Tapis !"   *Exclamation des spectateurs*
"Wahou, ah ouais il sent fort .." En plus, le lendemain de ta raclette, il te reste toujours du fromage,
du coup pour le finir, tu rachètes des pommes de terre et de charcuterie..
Mais après il te reste de la charcuterie, du coup pour la finir tu rachètes des pommes de terre et du fromage .. Mais du coup après,
il te reste des pommes de terre ...
donc tu rachètes de la charcuterie et du fromage, et après tu recommences plusieurs fois, et après tu meurs....
Ou en fait, finalement le seul moyen de mettre vraiment un terme à la raclette, bah c'est de faire ça !
"OH NON !!" - "Ah bah c'est déjà fini?"
"Attend j'ai mangé que 25 poêlerons .." - "Moi j'ai même pas encore mal au ventre!" -  "Ah mais pareil,  je ressens même pas encore l'envie de péter !"
En tout cas, les gens qui aiment pas la raclette moi je trouve c'est un peu comme les gens qui aiment pas Game Of Thrones
Ça les énerve que nous on aime .. Laissez-nous kiffer !
On vous a rien fait, même si on est d'accord que pour avoir une parfaite santé, c'est quand même mieux bah, de manger des légumes,
de boire de l'eau, de pas grignoter entre les repas, de faire du sport...  Oh et puis merde, mangeons de la raclette !
Vous êtes sur un téléphone ? Alors appuyez avec votre doigt sur ma grosse tête ici pour vous abonner facilement !
Et en fait ça marche aussi depuis un ordi !
~Alors, elle est pas belle la vie ?~
Bonsoir !